let's bring in the daily wires
editor-in-chief ben shapiro good to see
you Ben
aru let's take a look at some of the
recent negative headlines from some of
these media outlets almost blaming
President Trump for Rory Moore losing
the Alabama race what do you make of
that well I mean it's not president
Trump's fault that and more loss the
race it's remoras fault that Roy Moore
lost the race I mean he's the one who's
hit with all the allegations he was the
one who ran a pretty bad campaign he's
the one who should have dropped out
earlier President Trump intervened at
the last minute to try and save right
more from himself and obviously failed
in that effort but that's not untrue
merely as much as it's on Moore and
people who are backing more to the hill
it's like Steve Bennett the attempts by
the media to try and paint this as a
trump failure it just drives with
everything else the media it says about
Trump everything is a trump failure I
mean when Trump does something that's
eminently good like saying that
Jerusalem is Israel's capital and then
it turns out that a bunch of Muslim
fanatics decide to pursue violence in
Sweden and that's somehow Trump's fault
when there is some sort of economic bump
but it's not - the media's liking then
somehow that's a trump shortcoming no
matter what happens is Trump's fault
that gets pretty tiresome pretty quickly
which is why the American has basically
tuned out the media when it comes to
their assessments of from failings the
American public know that the the
economy is good and that Trump has had a
lot to do with that and the American
public know that a lot of the bad things
that happen in life have nothing to do
with the President of the United States
at all you know former NBA player and
Alabama native he's Charles Barkley he's
happy about Doug Jones election win
let's roll tape but watch your reaction
to it I love my state we got some
amazing people here yeah we got a bunch
of rednecks and a bunch of ignorant
people but we got some amazing people
here and they rose up today the
consensus among Republicans been is that
you know Roy Moore was a damaged
candidate Karl Rove just moments ago
there's breathing a sigh of a leaf that
he didn't win what do you what's your
reaction to Charles Barkley there I
think that that Barkley is painted with
a pretty broad brush when he suggests
that everyone who voted for Roy Moore
some sort of hick and it's that sort of
language that I think led to President
Trump in the first place was this sort
of dismissal of everyone who votes for a
bad flawed Republican candidate I
wouldn't have voted for as some somehow
backwards or stupid there are a lot of
people voted for Roy Moore because they
Doug Jones would be a worse senator for
the state of Alabama than Roy Moore at
least in terms of their policy
priorities I may disagree with the moral
calculus but to dismiss everybody who
voted for Roy Moore has somehow
backwards is deeply derisive and I think
counterproductive you know there's a
study I think in June July August that
show the same number 91% of media
coverage of the president was negative
just getting back to that story I mean
it seems like there's been no change
what do you make of that well I wouldn't
expect there to be a change because the
media have already ramped it all the way
up to ten there's no but there's no
place for them to go from here what are
they gonna go to 99 percent so things
get really bad for Trump and this is
actually one of the problems for the
media they painted themselves into a
corner if something truly shocking
happens with President Trump no one's
gonna pay attention they've become the
boy who cried wolf
and they've cried wolf so many times
that nobody is going to take them
seriously if something truly bad were to
happen on the other hand if something
truly good happens they treated just
like something bad happening so again
their credibility has really been ruined
that's their own fault that really has
little to do throat thank you Ben
Shapiro we love having you come back
soon thanks so much